So in Monday's lecture,
we let something slip by all of us without
a comment that we probably should not
have let slip by. And it's
something I want to focus on today.
That is when we spelled out mill's harm
principle. I said, does everybody, sure.
They know what it means. Nevermind
whether you agree with it or not,
but whether you sure that you
understand what he's saying.
And we all agreed that
at least it was clear.
In fact though,
it's ambiguous and this is the highlighted
phrase here is the ambiguity I want
to focus on.
Um,
at the end of that long paragraph, I
read you when we, when Miller saying,
um,
if you think something's bad for
somebody or that they shouldn't do it,
remember I give you the x gave you the
example of going to law school when I
don't think it's good for you.
Um,
mill says those may be good reasons
for romance straighting with them or
reasoning with him or
persuading him or treating him,
but not for compelling him or visiting
him with any evil in case he decided to
do otherwise.
To justify that,
I need to justify forcing somebody to do
something or prohibiting somebody from
doing something. The conduct from
Wishard is desired to deter him,
must be calculated to produce evil,
to someone else must be calculated
to produce evil from someone else.
And there are two issues raised by that
phrase that I really want us to focus on
with laser like intensity.
In today's lecture,
the one is signaled by the passive
voice in it must be calculated with that
obviously puts on the table who
does the calculating, right?
And secondly,
what does it mean calculated?
It could be, it could mean
calculated as he an intended.
I didn't intend to harm you.
There was no calculation to
harm you when I got parallel,
literally drunk behind the wheel of a car.
And then I don't even remember putting
the keys in the wheel and driving out.
I didn't intend to harm you,
right?
Or is it a third party calculation,
um,
by again,
then we get to the question by whom?
Who's going to decide who's
going to do the calculating?
So what is calculated actually mean
and who is it that's going to do the
calculating? Those are the things
we're going to zero in on today.
And I thought the best way into
it was to consider some examples.
And when I left you with on Monday
was what about prostitution?
This is what is sometimes referred
to as a so called victimless crime.
After all,
um,
the chance action between the tropic
prostitute and a client is a parade.
Oh, superior transaction. Right?
It's a voluntary market transaction.
They wouldn't do it if it didn't
make both people better off.
Um, so should we just say
from male's point of view,
there's no harm here.
Truly is a victimless crime and we
shouldn't make things at all if they are
victimized.
How many people think that makes sense?
I about half the thanks. That doesn't
make sense. Nobody. Yeah. Okay.
So what, why, why doesn't it makes sense?
Somebody who thinks it doesn't make sense,
why is it not the over here?
You,
why were you thinking
it didn't make sense?
Okay.
Um,
even though it's victimless,
I think there's harming yourself
has some sort of implications.
I think there's this, oh, it's that
prostitute harming herself
sort of. I think I just like some moral
implications in there. Let's be going.
What kinds of implications?
Um,
yeah,
besides just like harming, I don't think
I said, okay, let me take that back.
Harming herself.
It might harm society in the sense
that it brings down society's a moral
standard.
Okay. It might harm society. Um,
males very clear that he wants to reject
the idea that there were social rights.
So, so he wouldn't accept that. But I
don't think you should give up so quickly.
Um,
is,
is there some other way of articulating
what you have in mind there?
When you say harm society,
what do you mean?
What if you unpack?
What does it mean when you really,
when you say harm society,
it's tricky.
Anyone else want to have a go?
Yeah, right behind you. Um,
I guess it poses a negative
externality on society. Okay.
What is the negative externality?
We'll,
I guess in the case of
prostitution and could be, um,
the objectification of women in this case,
objectification of women.
Okay. And that, that,
yep.
How would we say that's a harm to society?
Maybe it would be,
again,
a male's cannot reject the idea that
society has a right not to be harmed so
high.
How can it play out in a way that
doesn't involve making that plan?
It's society.
Okay.
Well,
I guess it,
you could say it poses a
negative externality on the
individuals and the society
by him August on women on women play
and it poses a negative externality on
women at reinforces a set of
stereotypes and so on. Okay.
So that might be one way in
which prostitution causes harm.
Any other ways?
Yes sir.
Um,
it could also be said that
it is a negative extra
nowaday because it undermines
family values.
It undermines fat family value,
which would then in turn like
hurt children and like the future
that would in turn her children.
Yeah.
Um, well I think it's difficult also
to just connect prostitution from the,
like this sort of theoretical model
from the actual model of prostitution.
I think when we put sort of,
you know,
pimps in sexual slavery and that
sort of thing into the picture,
then the harm becomes far more real and
it's questionable whether people are,
um, voluntarily participating in
these transactions to begin with.
Okay. So if you are really hard
boiled million libertarian,
I think why slavery is not an issue,
slaves or taken by force,
but, um, selling yourself
into indentured servitude,
not obviously something would Melsa
you should be allowed to do that.
Your choice
Trekkie was,
you're really giving up your, you're,
you're really giving up your Tonomy.
It's sort of, you'll see in politics,
we can front later in the course,
what do you do with an election where a
party runs as in Algeria in 1991 sang if
elected, we are going to abolish
democracy and they get elected,
uh,
should that,
you know, in the, in that
case, the Algerian military
stepped in. But, so should,
if somebody says, I'm going to sell myself
into servitude, it's a voluntary act,
should we save them from this themself?
Okay.
That,
that's a very tricky one.
But let's set those ones aside and I
think there would be similar issues with
suicide for mail.
Should you allow it be allowed to
stop people committing suicide?
Those are very hard. I think. Um,
there's separate though from these issues
about what we're calling externalities.
People are saying, of course there are
harmful effects of prostitution. It,
it harms women.
Um,
it may undermine certain
kinds of moral codes. Um,
what would males say in response to that?
Yeah.
Well, I think for me it really
depends on the context of an act.
So you can be drunk at home, but you
can't be a policemen drunk on the job.
So if we look at prostitution, if you're,
you know, working as a free agent,
sure you can engage in prostitution,
but if you're a father and you're married,
then he would probably view
that as something not okay.
So it really matters for him what the
context is of a certain transaction.
Okay. I think that's, that's right.
And you could imagine a more refined
version of the harm that tried to
incorporate that.
I gave the example last time,
I think I said male would presumably be
completely comfortable with outgrowing
drunk driving,
uh,
and punishing that activity but not
punishing drinking. So presumably, uh,
you know, the principal would be,
be some version of interfere with,
with human conduct as, as little as
possible to prevent harm. Right. So you,
it's,
it's killing a Gnat with a sledgehammer
to outlawed drinking just because some
people drive drunk. I think
that's fair enough. But,
but I think some of the people who are
saying allowing prostitution has big a
negative externalities wouldn't
give up that quickly. Anyone.
We think we shouldn't give up that
quickly. That there's something else here.
Nobody,
maybe they would give up that quick.
Yeah.
Okay. Well we'll, we'll just, we'll leave
that aside for a minute, but, uh, and,
and come back to it.
So
if you, if you, if you now bearing
this in mind, go back and reread,
um, on liberty. I think what
you'll come away with is,
it's actually quite confusing.
Just what mail means by harm,
because that some harms he
wants to say are trivial harms.
So the harm you Safa through
not getting a place in college,
in a competitive exam, right?
He's knocking out loud.
That harm ultimately to be dispositive,
it's going to allow that to be
outweighed by the benefits to society of
competitive meritocracy.
Uh,
and remember our three
straight discussion last time.
So some harms are more significant
than other harms and some harms are
outweighed by utilitarian benefits.
It seems like some of the time if he's,
you know,
mail saying,
um,
prohibition shouldn't be allowed.
He's saying essentially, you know,
unless I intend to do you some harm,
you might find it offensive that
I sit around drinking all day.
But you know,
it's not know your business.
You might have family values which say,
um,
uh,
that,
that if there are people out
there who are prostitutes,
it undermines the family. That's your
family value. Thank you very much.
It's not my family value, right? So you
could take that view. And after all,
if you think about the,
the debate we've had in this country
about gay marriage over the past decade or
so, that's exactly what the, the claim and
the counterclaim, right? Some people say,
um,
there's no reason in the world that gay
people should be prevented from getting
married. They're not hurting anybody else.
Uh, and then, you know, people say, well,
that undermines traditional family
values, right? And the, the,
the people who support gay
marriage say, well, so what,
those are your traditional family values,
but they're not out traditional
family values. And why should yours?
This is awful. The what mill says the
tyranny of majority opinions. So what,
right. This is supposed to protect
individual freedom against,
okay?
So one person's traditional family
values is another person's tyranny of a
majority opinion.
How are you going to resolve that?
What mechanisms does smell
have to resolve that?
And I think you could read on liberty
with a fine tooth comb and not come up
with one.
Okay?
And so you could say,
well,
so much the worst for male.
We thought we had this wonderful reits,
utilities synthesis,
you know,
we're all good things would go together.
We could respect individual
freedoms and promotes social,
a utilitarian efficiency based
on science all at the same time.
But actually it turns out to all be,
uh,
resting on a hail of sand.
And the minute you walk on
it, you start sinking. Um,
and I think this is a,
this is a good time to go back to the
point I made to you right at the beginning
of the course when I said,
um,
you shouldn't be expecting the
sell silver bullet in this course.
You shouldn't be expecting to find the
theory that answers all your questions.
What instead you're going to find this
particular insights that you can pick up
and put into your bag of
tricks and move on with,
because I think it is at the end of the
day a good critique of mill to say there
is no single definition of harm and
there's no good account of who makes the
decisions about harm. Uh,
and so to that extent, um,
his claim at the beginning of on liberty,
that there's one simple principle
and this is what it is, fails.
Nonetheless,
there's some important and
enduring insights here that
I think we're not getting
one to let go off.
One is
okay.
When you think about all of the ways human
beings interact and all of the things
we do that cause us to have the
possibility of bumping into one another,
maybe it shouldn't be the case that there
is a single definition of harm because
different definitions of harm
are relevant to different
types of situation.
This is a little like the point somebody
here made that Mel would be interested
in the context.
If you think about,
um,
physicians,
we allow physicians to buy malpractice
insurance in case they kill you by
mistake when they're doing surgery.
But we don't allow bank robbers to buy
malpractice insurance so that if they
kill you by mistake when they're
robbing a bank, they can, they can, uh,
get off.
That tells you right there,
there must be different conceptions
of harm that operate in different
circumstances.
And indeed,
if you want to start thinking
about it a little bit more, uh,
systematically harm is treated very
differently in different situations.
Think about this continuum I've
put up here some kinds of harm.
Arec, completely excluded. You're not,
you're not held responsible for them at
all. If, if you have a death penalty,
a Neagle execution of people,
of course you harm the person,
you execute certain kinds of,
of wartime killing.
Of course you harm the person
that you kill. But we allow it.
We don't count it as a relevant harm.
Then here I'm going down this continuum.
We say that the intention to kill is
very important in the criminal law.
We have this idea,
anyone know what this term,
mens rea is and the criminal law,
no reason you should,
but somebody might.
Yeah.
If,
if you're charging somebody
with a criminal offense
that the government has to
prove beyond a reasonable doubt,
various elements of the crime
that the person did it, um,
that,
that there was in fact that the crime
occurred and that there was something
called the mens rea or criminal
intent, guilty mind. That's,
that's what it means.
I'm in the criminal law when we make
that one of the elements of the crime.
That's why
things like the insanity defense becomes
so contentious because the person
claims, while I didn't have, because
I didn't know what I was doing,
I didn't have mens rea.
My client didn't have man's dre.
He didn't know what he was doing,
so he's not guilty by reason
of insanity is not guilty.
Okay. Or if you think
about, you might say,
well we do,
we do imprison people for Valet vehicular
homicide when they get drunk and the
person says,
but I didn't intend to kill them.
I didn't know that I, I didn't know I
was driving. How can you say intended?
Interestingly, there we come up with
a doctrine of in the legal system,
which we call constructive intent and
what is the doctrine of a construct of
intent. It's basically we say, well,
any reasonable person would know that if
you drive down to a bar and you have no
way to get home and you
then drink 10 beers,
you would be,
you would be putting yourself in
position where you could harm someone.
So construct,
we're going to impute the intent to you,
even though you didn't have it.
That's the doctrine of constructive
intent that's using exactly that kind of
situation.
So in the criminal law to go back to mail,
we'd say calculated to produce evil in
someone else has got to be calculated by
the person committing the harm.
Okay.
So why is that? You might say, well,
criminal actions are actions
which bring moral disapproval,
a program on people.
We lock them up.
They're really thinks we
don't want people to do.
And we want people to internalize
the incentive not to do them.
So it's about their intentional actions
and then we punish them for those
actions. And therefore,
um, we want, when we,
when we put sanctions on them,
we want them to know,
uh,
that they could have behaved otherwise.
And so we want the intent to be pricing.
So construct them in Canada
is sort of like intent,
but not exactly
what about negligence.
Negligence is even less
like constructive intent.
So negligence is the doctrine that let's
suppose you're living in a neighborhood
where there are lots of children,
well children and you put
in a swimming pool. Um, and,
and let's say the law requires that there
be your fence and your swimming pool,
but you leave the,
you leave the fence,
open the gate open and
at child goes hand in,
falls into your pool and drowns.
The doctrine of negligence would say,
well yeah,
she of course you're dating in 10 the
that the child would drown but you were
negligent and leaving your door open or
you're, you're leaving the gate open.
So we're going to hold you responsible.
So it's,
it's a little less than constructive
intent. It's negligent. You were,
any reasonable person would know that
you shouldn't leave the
gate open. So you were, um,
it's still a state of mind, but it's
obviously not the same thing. Um,
as
intending to kill the child.
And then we could go even further
down the continuum and say, you know,
there's some situations where we say,
we don't care about your
state of mind at all.
So if an adult has sex with a 14 year old
yeah.
And walks in and says,
well your honor,
she said she was 20 and
I thought she was 20,
she looked 20 and,
and perhaps that's true.
Perhaps all of those things were true.
She said she was 20.
I thought she was 20 and she looked 20.
We don't care.
We say as a society,
we don't care.
Okay.
That's the notion of statutory rape.
It's or sometimes called strict liability.
We're going to hold you liable anyway.
And why do we do that?
Presumably to give people the incentive
to make sure to as defined out.
Um,
so when we say if she was 14 it statutory
rape or if he was 14 and she was 20,
it's statutory right?
There it is. Uh, too bad.
We don't care what she said. And, um,
we don't care what you, you believed
at the time because we want to,
to ensure that people have the
incentive to find that out correctly.
Or we could think of Good Samaritan laws.
This is the situation where you're walking
along a and you see somebody drowning
in a lake and had very little cost
to yourself. You could pull them out,
but you say, you know, I'm
late for class and my mind,
your, you know, I didn't
push you in the lake.
In many states we have good
Samaritan laws, which if it,
if it really wasn't no trivial cost
to yourself, you could have done that.
You can be prosecuted for failing to
assist somebody in need of your help.
Okay.
So that's obviously a very
capacious definition of harm.
I mean,
after all,
the fact that we're all sitting here
rather than doing relief work in Haiti
right now means presumably
that some people are suffering,
perhaps even dying as a result of
our failure to go to Haiti right now.
So it,
once you go over this line
into set treating omissions
to help as a form of harm
as we do with good Samaritan laws,
where will it end?
Right?
So you can see from this that if you
wanted one definition of harm to cover all
situations, that obviously isn't
gonna make any sense. Nonetheless,
if you, it, you think
about this continuum, um,
where you fall on,
it has huge implications for how
you're gonna run your society.
And more interestingly than that,
these things,
this, I've given you a
kind of static picture now,
but these things actually change.
Think about the drug thalidomide.
Who knows what happened
with the letter mine. Yeah.
What happened with the later mine.
Okay.
Um,
it came out in the late fifties.
It was used to treat morning
sickness and it turns out that, uh,
the re-estimate of the drug,
uh,
causes teratoma and children
born to women taking the drug.
And so it was basically a failure of the
drug industry to look into the effects
of, um, the different
structures of drugs in humans.
Correct. Okay. And what's,
that's a very good summary.
And what's interesting about thalidomide
from our point of view is that the,
in developing this drug which was
given for morning sickness, um,
the comp, the drug, the pharmaceutical
companies didn't cut any corners.
They did all that,
the clinical trials correctly,
they got the FDA approvals, everything
was done by the book. There was not,
there was no, uh,
nothing illicit was done.
And at that time,
the general stand it
in tort liability.
That is tort tort does,
who knows what tort means?
T O r t not T. O. R. T. A.
We're not talking about chocolate cake.
What's a tort?
Nobody knows what a tort is
toward. Just means harm, right?
So the general standard for Tort
liability was negligence and
they weren't negligent. They did
it by the book. They got all,
they got all of the approvals,
they got the clinical trials,
the FDA approved the drug.
And it's a famous case because it was an
instrument by which the courts decided
to say, you know what? We don't care.
We don't care. They moved
from negligence, negligence,
strict liability. We don't care
that you did it. All right.
The fact is there are all of
these children who are born with
missing limbs and you're going to pay you,
the drug companies are going to pay.
We're going to hold you strictly liable.
We're going to treat it like the
example I gave before statutory.
Right now you might say, well
why, why would you do that?
And interestingly,
the the move in American tort law
from negligence to strict liability,
those of you who go to go on
from here to the yell loss go,
we'll learn all about it
because the intellectual,
a giant of the move from the negligence
to strict liability was Guido Kalibrasi,
longtime dean of the Yale Law School
and now a federal judge on the second
circuit.
Um,
he wrote a book called the
costs of accidents and the
main argument of the costs
of accidents, it was, this was
actually about auto accidents.
It was essentially utilitarian in that
caliber breezy looked at free for,
um,
okay,
what had already started in,
in New Jersey at that time.
If people rear end one another in,
in cars,
you can say, well, what,
who was negligent care?
Was it the driver in front or
why is it the dryer in the back?
If it was the driver
in the front, why? Oh,
well he stopped too quickly or
something like that. Will, you know, uh,
something like that. Or the
driver at the back says, well,
my brakes weren't working.
Or the driver at the front light brake
lights weren't working or something like,
you know,
you have an argument and they have their
lawyer and you have your lawyer and you
Duke it out and somebody wins and
somebody loses is how many New Jersey said
it's not worth it.
It's a waste of court time.
It's a waste of everybody's time.
So we're going to make the law,
which says in an in rear ending situation,
the car,
the driver at the back pays
always kind of rough justice.
Sometimes. Maybe the brake lights on
the front car really weren't working.
We don't care.
It's just not worth the state of New
Jersey's time to invest in institutional
resources and all the rest of it to allow
people to litigate these things just
just cost too much.
It's not worth it.
So Guido Calabresi came up with a
little algorithm in which he said the
standards should be to minimize the costs
of accidents plus the costs of their
avoidance.
So you figure out the costs of,
of all the rear ending, right? And then
you say to yours and then you figure out,
well, if we allow people to, so what's
the cost of avoiding accidents that way?
Whereas if we allow, if we don't
allow them to sue for negligence,
what's the cost? That way it's cheaper.
It's more efficient and anyway,
way probably property.
Some good side benefits.
It gives the person at the back the
right incentive to keep a distance.
They can stop, right? Uh,
so we make a utilitarian judge chess not,
you know,
the game's not worth the
candle for negligence.
Hmm.
That's one defense. Hobbit. Um,
coming back to the thalidomide,
minimize the costs of accidents
and the costs of their avoidance.
What do we want as a society?
We want the drug companies to have the
incentive to go the extra mile to do even
more research.
Then they didn't have to do restaurant
Clyde by the FDA to buy the insurance
because perhaps they're
the deepest pocket.
They have the resources to do the
research and to buy the insurance.
If you're thinking about
if you're a pregnant woman,
thinking about taking a morning
sickness pill or not taking it,
you don't have the resources
to do extra research. Um,
okay.
So we put,
we put the burden on the party
who can most cheaply avoid it.
Now the drug companies, that's
outrageous. It's totally outrageous.
We didn't do anything wrong. And
you're punishing us. Strict liability.
So we moved and,
and the example of thalidomide is just
a tip of an iceberg and the hall of Tort
Law,
there's been this 30 or 40 year move
from a negligence standard to a strict
liability standard NF.
Fascinating intellectual debate between
Kalibrasi who is the champion of strict
liability and Richard Posner, who you
will probably have read some of his books,
a judge and the Chicago circuit who
defends negligence as more efficient.
So it's an, it's a debate between
utilitarians in that sense. And if,
if we had more time,
I would have you read some of that debate.
Um,
but as a matter of the,
you might say,
you might be convinced at the end of
it that Posner winds intellectually,
but as a matter of the politics of it,
Kalibrasi wins.
That is to say American tort law has
moved since the 1950s away from strict
liability, uh, away from
negligence, strict liability.
Let's think of another example.
In the 1950s in America,
a high spend could not be
prosecuted for raping his wife.
There was no such crime.
It was, in other words,
a conclusive common law presumption
that there was no such crime.
Now, you might say, why? While
there's a historical answer,
a went back to then the suspension of
the legal identity of the woman during
marriage,
essentially all it goes back
to the old patriarchal laws.
The daughter was more or
less the father's property,
and then he gave his property
to the son in law as,
as the husband's property.
So the woman didn't,
didn't have a legal identity as a
person during marriage. And this is why,
uh, she lost control
of her property. Right.
And that was restored ultimately by
the myriad woman's property acts,
um,
that re recreated a women's property
rights of a say inherited wealth or
whatever it was. It didn't automatically
become her husband's property,
but there was this hang of a
from the 19th century that,
um,
okay,
a woman, a woman couldn't
be right by her husband, uh,
and not only write but other things
like assault. So in other words, uh,
a woman you could walk up to a woman
you are not married to on the street and
punch her in the face and get arrested
for that and convicted of assault.
But if you did it to your wife,
there was no crime.
So then we have,
yeah,
the women's movement,
we have a lot of feminists
pressure an organization.
And so we now have gone
to a world in which, um,
marital rape is a felony in about 45
of the states and the federal system.
So it's gone from being,
having a conclusive common
law presumption against it,
to making it a felony. And all the
other things have gone as well.
So into spousal tort,
immunity is gone. Uh,
you can be prosecuted for assaulting.
In other words,
marriage is no longer a bar.
Two things that would be
criminal actions outside. So we,
we've had a huge change in the law there
from one definition of what counts as
are relevant harm to a
different definition of what
counts as irrelevant harm.
In the first case,
it was an argument about efficiency.
And the second is a political movement.
Uh,
the women's movement had this enormous
impact on the redefinition of what sorts
of harms the state should
take seriously in marriage.
Let me give you a third example.
Okay.
If you go into employment
law, housing law, um,
or education,
mmm.
The American courts have for many decades,
at least since Brown vs board of
education was a handed down by a unanimous
supreme court in 1954.
They've been concerned with trying
to get rid of discrimination.
Discrimination is a kind of harm,
right?
So the question is,
what do you have to show?
What do you have to show to convince
the court that you been harmed?
Initially there should be a remedy.
What do you have to shout?
And during the Warren Court,
it was somewhat like strict liability.
The Warren Court,
all Warren was appointed by
President Eisenhower in 1953.
Eisenhower authority was
appointing a conservative justice,
but he turned out to be wrong.
Oh,
Warren was perhaps the most liberal,
uh,
chief justice of the 20th century.
And He, the, the court under his,
under his leadership,
uh,
develop the idea that all you had to
do was show there was a pattern of
discriminatory effects.
You didn't have to show that any buddy
intended to discriminate against anyone.
So in the education area,
separate but equal,
the court said is inherently unequal.
It doesn't,
we're not saying that
that white southerners are
necessarily prejudice against
blacks. Many of them were, but we don't,
we're not getting get to that question.
We just sang separate,
but equal is inherently
impossible. It's an oxymoron.
You can't have it. Uh,
and we were saying that without
reference to the intentions of school
administrators or anybody else, um, in,
in housing patterns,
if you see, um, you know,
you do these kinds of studies
like ens and the Yale law school,
he has a well known for having done,
um,
when people with exactly the
same objective characteristics,
same income,
same employment history and
saw and going for a mortgage.
It turns out that African Americans are
denied mortgages at a higher rate than
non African Americans.
You don't have to show that that mortgage
officer was a racist doors in Kandin
you just, you, you produced this
to test x. You show, you know,
people at these objective characteristics
who are African American get denied.
And these are those the same act,
the same characteristics who are not
African Americans don't get denied.
It's a pattern of discriminatory effects.
We don't have to get into
something like man's rail,
whatever's going on in the the
bank mortgage offices head.
So that was the standard also
in employment discrimination
and many other areas
of the law of under the Warren Court.
All you had to show was a pattern of
discriminatory effects by the Warren court
was gradually replaced. First buy the
Burger court, then the rank was cord,
and now the Roberts court.
And in that conservative evolution,
discrimination law has gone
this way on the continuum.
Now you can't get a remedy unless you
can show the part the intention to
discriminate on the part
of some public official.
So let's say in zoning ordinances,
you've got to show that some
public official actually
tried to do the zoning in
such a way as to exclude blacks from
a certain neighborhood, let's say,
um,
before you couldn't get a remedy.
So an employment we've been and,
and housing and education and all
of these areas of discrimination,
we've gone the other way as a
society, right? We've gone from a,
a very capacious standed,
which would allow us,
allow our remedy just from
the objective indicators,
the patterns of discriminatory effects.
Now we treat it more like the,
the criminal law we say,
unless you can show the,
you can establish in
court that there was some
particular person in that bank denying
mortgages who intended to discriminate,
no remedy.
So it's much harder of
course to get remedies.
So those are three examples.
Those are three examples.
The thalidomide,
the marital rape and the discrimination
where you can see that this enormous
flux in our society as to what
counts as are relevant harm.
Yeah.
You know,
and if we had time,
I strongly suspect if we had time to
have a debate in this room on those three
topics, it's not like we
would, we would all agree
as to, you know, whether in
discrimination law it should be
okay.
Patent has no discriminatory
effects or intent.
We'd have a differences
of opinion about that.
That would stem from our assumptions
about the appropriate role of government,
um,
how intrusive it should be and so on.
Or probably there would be less,
there would be less disagreement
today about the marital rape.
Then there would have been in the 1950s
and I suspect intuitions would go all
over the place, uh, about
okay,
tort liability and that's the later mine.
So what does that tell us?
This is the second reason I think it's
really instructive to work through
somebody like Mel.
Even if in the end,
Mel doesn't have the answer.
I think one of the,
the lessons of this course, and this is,
you can see it here very dramatically,
is that it's,
it is impossible
to get rid of political disagreement.
It is impossible to
reduce political choices,
to sign Catholic choices all the way down.
Science can play important roles
in making political choices,
but they can't,
it can't make them for us.
So that one of the big
goals of the enlightenment
to come up with scientific principles of
politics is never going to be perfectly
realized. That doesn't mean it
can't be partially realized,
but it's never going to
be perfectly realize.
You can't ring the
politics out of politics.
There's no way to do it.
And so you know if you will,
you will see when we come to read Marx
and he talks about his utopian communist
society. One of his is great guys. Great.
One Line is one of his one
liners is that politics at the,
at the end of the day when we finally
have the true communist Utopia,
politics will be replaced
by administration, right?
That's a bumper sticker for saying
we're going to ring the politics out of
politics.
Bentham,
okay.
Looking for the right objective,
utilitarian calculus, right?
Mel wants to say while
once the harm is triggered,
we can bring,
we can,
we can do the cost benefit
analysis on scientific principles.
We talked about that last time.
Never works.
It never works all the way
down. It doesn't mean to say
that scientific thinking,
current condition,
our normative choices,
but you'll go back and think through
these three examples that I've just given
you. These are basically
normative choices, right?
In the 1950s when this issue
about marital rape came up,
a lot of things were sad that a seminar
to what is said now about gay marriage,
people said,
if the state starts prosecuting husbands,
we're going to destroy
the traditional family.
You know, and people in the
women's movement said, great,
we're going to destroy this traditional
family because at g man shouldn't be
allowed to write women, at least in
this respect. We want to write that.
So traditional values only takes you
so far because the harm principle is,
you know,
by definition,
a critical principle for looking
at traditional values and saying,
how much should we cater to them?
How much not right?
So
these are political choices.
The choice about the letter might
has huge distributed consequences,
right? You Do, you normous
you're going to say to,
to pharmaceutical companies, you're going
to be liable from now on for the harm,
harmful effects of your drugs,
regardless of whether you got the
FDA approval that that has put,
it's a huge,
it's a huge burden to put on them.
You notice what we could say,
we could say no.
You know,
as a famous libertarian judge
learned hand said in society losses,
Miss Lie, where they
fall. What does that mean?
It basically means the women who had the
thalidomide children and the children
themselves must internalize the loss.
Or we could say,
we'll socialize,
we will socialize the risk,
we'll say in in these kinds of situations
when there was no wrong doing
in the sense of cutting corners,
the government will bail them out.
You know,
just like we did after nine 11 we
created this huge fund and paid paid
compensation to people,
to the relatives of people who died at
nine and 11 many people die all the time
and in disasters where we don't do that,
but we could,
we could have massive social
insurance for unexpected harms,
right?
So the choice to say losses,
Ms lie where they fall with learning hand,
right?
Or that we should socialize it
by saying, well, if, if you,
if you are born with a physical deformity,
obviously it's through
no fault of your own,
but really you can't blame the
manufacturer of thalidomide either.
So the state will pick it up.
We as a society will do it.
That's a different
choice. Or if you say, no,
we're going to make the letter MyEd
the manufacturer internalize this.
That's a different choice.
My point he has, it's,
it's always a choice.
It's always a choice.
We'll come to read a, a libertarian
called Robert Nozick later in the course.
And one of his one line is,
is that the question of political theory
is whether or not they should be a
state.
But we'll see that that's a bit like
saying the fundamental question of dental
theory is whether or not
they should be teeth.
Okay?
Because in fact,
everything involves collective choices.
Even the collective choice to let
the loss. Why lie, where it falls,
that is itself a collective choice.
So you can't ring the politics
out of politics and the,
at least one goal of the enlightenment.
We're going to see this,
this idea of re replacing politics
with science or in this formulation of
politics being displaced by administration
can never be perfectly realized.
And that's an important insight
we get from thinking about, uh,
trying to apply mill's harm
principle. Okay. See you on Monday.